Alex: Wooo! Live from the gap between Lisbon and New York. Welcome back to The Office 360 Unfiltered. I am Alex. This episode is the anatomy of the studio itself, and it is sponsored by Klear. Four senior people. Two cities. And how we out-build a fifty person agency that needs a meeting to schedule a meeting. If you have ever paid for a building and got a hallway, come on. This one is for you.
Morgan: Ha, he packed the manifesto into the open. I'm Morgan. Here is the traditional anatomy. Account manager. Then a project manager. Then a junior who actually touches the files. Then a senior who reviews it on Friday if nobody is on PTO. You paid for a studio. You got a hallway with name tags. The Office 360 is four seniors. You talk to the people who write the code. No intern maze. Lisbon to New York, same Slack, same repo, same standard.
Alex: And that only works because the process is boring in the best way. Fixed scope. Fixed price. You know the number before we write a line. Automated QA, so we are not babysitting a stack that wants to break every Tuesday. No proprietary theme. No, wait for the junior to get unblocked. Authors, schools, publishers, churches, you do not need fifty people. You need four who have done this, and a contract that hands you the keys.
Morgan: The client-truth version. When something breaks at nine at night in New York, you are not opening a ticket that lands in a queue in another time zone with a bot. You are talking to the person whose name is on the commit. That is the whole flex. Small on purpose. Senior on purpose. Two cities on purpose, because the work is async and the standard is not. If a fifty person deck impressed you and the site still loads like 2012, you already know.
Alex: We do three-click discoverability. We do Jamstack when it should be Jamstack. We do not sell you a retainer to click update plugins. We do not hide juniors in the spreadsheet. When the invoice is paid, you own every line of code. That is not a slogan. That is how a four person senior studio beats a hallway. Clean architecture. Clean process. And yes, clean fuel, because this episode is sponsored by Klear, Klear with a K.
Morgan: Two cities, long days, nobody on this team is slamming a chalky milkshake between calls. Traditional protein is thick, secret, and sits in your stomach like a proprietary theme. Klear is clear whey isolate. You can literally see it. Twenty grams of protein, zero sugar, zero lactose, about ninety calories. We earn a commission if you use our code. That keeps this live show on the air, and I would rather tell you that than hide it.
Alex: Strawberry watermelon is the one. Wild blue raspberry if you want the tang. One scoop, twelve ounces of water, shake it, let it settle a minute, drink it like a sports drink, not a gym brick. Exclusive twenty percent off, the best cut they are giving. Code MARKETPL. klearprotein.com/discount/MARKETPL. Use that link, not a random one. Same rule as the repo. Use the keys that are actually yours.
Morgan: Homework. If you are still in a hallway, ask who actually writes your code. If the answer is a junior you have never met, call us. theoffice360.com. Code STUDIO50. Fifty percent off the studio tiers. Turnkey Build, IA Roadmap, HTTPS Security. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com. Four people. Lisbon to New York. You own the work.
Alex: I love this show because the studio and the shaker are the same philosophy. Don't rent a fifty person performance. Don't swallow the heavy version because a brochure said protein. Small on purpose. Clear on purpose. Authors, schools, publishers, churches, if your site needs a meeting to schedule a meeting, it is not your people. It is the hallway. We build, we hand you the keys, we get out of the way.
Morgan: If your protein still tastes like chalk, Klear, klearprotein.com, code MARKETPL, twenty percent off. If your agency is a hallway, you know where we live. I'm Morgan, he's Alex, this was The Office 360 Unfiltered, from Lisbon to New York, sponsored by Klear. We love you. Bye!